- Il y a 50 ans que Guy Lafleur
a porté ce chandail numéro 4
avec les Remparts et pour lequel
la Ville de Québec lui rend
hommage. Mais pour lui,
c'est comme si c'était hier.
GUY LAFLEUR, ancien joueur
des Canadiens de Montréal
- Je me souviens qu'à l'époque,
j'étais en train de déjeuner
avec Jean Béliveau chez lui,
puis... il me disait :
"Tu vas voir, ça passe vite."
Bon, j'ai 19 ans, ça passera
pas si vite que ça!
(rires)
Je dois vous avouer une chose :
je l'ai pas vu passer!
- Ému et émouvant, affaibli par
son combat contre le cancer,
Guy Lafleur a été touché par
l'oeuvre de Guillaume Tardif.
"Trop fort pour la ligue",
ce qu'il était à l'époque
des Remparts, avec qui
il a inscrit presque
300 buts en deux saisons.
- C'était extraordinaire.
On avait... je dirais,
de 12 à 15 autobus qui
nous suivaient partout
à travers la ligue. C'était...
les gens venaient au Colisée,
puis ils couchaient là le soir
pour avoir des billets.
- Parmi ses fans, il y avait
sans doute un jeune Réal
Cloutier qui, inspiré par
le numéro 4, allait devenir,
lui aussi, une vedette adulée
des amateurs de Québec,
une vedette à qui on rend
aussi hommage aujourd'hui.
RÉAL CLOUTIER, ancien joueur
des Nordiques de Québec
- C'est vraiment mon image,
t'sais, ma tenue quand je jouais
au hockey, le bâton comme ça.
C'est une journée de
reconnaissance épouvantable.
Moi, je viens de Québec, je suis
pas loin, je suis en dedans
de 10 km du Colisée puis toute.
CHRISTIAN BORDELEAU, ancien
joueur des Nordiques de Québec
- Que ce soit dans le hockey
mineur, les Remparts,
les Nordiques, il a fait
sa marque d'une façon
extraordinaire.
MARC TARDIF, ancien joueur
des Nordiques de Québec
- C'est quelque chose de beau...
On était bien contents pour
Buddy. Ouais, il le mérite.
- Un bel honneur pour
les deux hockeyeurs,
un cadeau que Guy Lafleur,
qui dit vivre au jour le jour,
veut savourer pleinement.
- Parce que quand on est jeune,
on prend tout pour acquis,
on n'apprécie pas.
C'est normal, ça nous est dû,
mais... Je pense que vieillir,
aujourd'hui, c'est un privilège
qu'on a. Savourer chaque
moment... puis c'est ce qu'on...
fait, alors un gros, gros merci
de votre présence, puis...
(applaudissements)
... bonne santé à tout le monde!
- Guy! Guy! Guy!
- Ici Jean-Philippe Martin,
Radio-Canada,